so during your studies you're probably
really busy trying to manage courses
friends family etc but you also want to
get these opportunities while still
being able to watch your favorite
netflix shows so i compiled a list of
three tips that i wish i knew during my
bachelor's and my master's that allowed
me to get a lot more opportunities later
in life so the first tip i want to give
is to put your work online as soon as
you start university in any type of way
because that's something i really regret
it so austen cleon says in his book show
your work that if your work is not
online it doesn't really exist and i
actually agree with this so i would
encourage you to think about what you
use in your studies or during your
studies and try to see if you can
somehow reinvent it and put it online so
think about if you're doing coding if
you're using some github code think
about publishing your code as well or if
you love watching study with me youtube
tutorials or videos think about making
one yourself or even if you're reading a
lot of interesting articles i think it's
really nice if you put it on twitter for
example and shout out an article that
you really like and i think by doing
this you kind of build your own
knowledge system a little bit faster
because by trying to explain something
that you learned to someone else that is
so much more difficult than just
learning it for yourself and i think
secondly it is also a really good way to
build up your cv so during my bachelor's
i did a lot of computational projects
but i never put them on github and i now
kind of regret that because it would
have been really good during any type of
technical interview to show what i had
already accomplished on github and i
think lastly it can also really create
these kind of golden nuggets so if you
for example write a blog post on your
first year of your bachelor and you do
this every week at the end of the year
you would have 52 blog posts that could
perhaps get picked up by someone that
really likes it and i think by doing
this you can kind of create your own
following so the second advice i would
give to my younger self is to look into
lab rotations internships and
scholarships as soon as possible because
when i was still living in the
netherlands i thought people like me
couldn't really get a scholarship in my
home country but actually if you look at
countries abroad a lot of countries are
offering specifically for foreign
students really good scholarships or
really good lab rotations slash
internships so i think trying to find
internships laborations and scholarships
is actually not as hard as you think if
you're willing to look outside of your
own country and the added benefit of
that is that you get a really good
travel experience so one of the places i
would look if you want to study in any
country in the european union you have
these marie curry brands that you can
apply to and they're relatively not
super difficult to get i think so yeah
and also for lab rotations something i
did during my bachelor is that i just
emailed professors that i really liked
and this way i scored a really cool
laboration in germany which i also got a
small stipend for so i think just trying
to reach out to people and ask if they
have any type of opportunity for you
even if you're just a bachelor or just a
first year i think this is a really good
experience and kind of teaches you how
to apply for scholarships slash
laborations slash internships and also
how to get them and the last thing to
get more opportunities is also to be
open and willing to give more
opportunities to others so i think if
you are a little bit further in your
studies to help for example
undergraduates or some of your
colleagues finish some of their papers
or thesis is a really good way to get
more opportunities yourself as well
because i think training juniors helping
friends with papers and joining bigger
projects in the end you can become for
example a second author or you can have
just a really good learning experience
of mentoring someone because i think
mentoring people is not valued enough
but i do think if you are a really good
mentor usually trainees really
appreciate you for the longer time so i
would really encourage you if you are a
little bit further in your studies to
also spread the knowledge that you have
gathered so thank you for listening to
this video and if you are struggling a
little bit with your productivity i also
made another video specifically about
productivity and otherwise i wish you a
really good week and see you next time
bye